اذا تحولت قضيه اللاجئين السوريين الى ملف
رئيسي في حملات الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في تركيا واليوم هي العنوان
الابرز لاستقطاب الناخبين للجوله الثانيه
في 28 من مايو والتي اكد فيها اوغاند زعمه
لاردوغان بعدما كان مشترطا طرد اللاجئين
السوريين مقابل هذا الدعم اما الرئيس
التركي اردوغان فنفى رضوخه لشروط
لكنه في الوقت ذاته اكد بانه يعد خطه
لعوده مليون لاجئ سوري الى بلادهم بعد
دراسه للتوقيت المناسب لضمان عودتهم كلام
اردوغان مشاهدينا جاء رد مباشر على منافسه
في انتخابات الرئاسه كمال كلتش دار اوغلو
بشان ياتي حل قضيه عوده اللاجئين السوريين
في غضون سنتين في حال تم انتخابه
رئيسا لتركيا وتشديد الاجراءات لمكافحه
الهجره غير الشرعيه السلطات التركيه ذكرت
في يناير الماضي بان عدد اللاجئين
السوريين الموجودين في تركيا يبلغ ثلاثه
فاصله خمسه مليون شخص وخلال عام 2022 عاد
الى سوريا نحو 59 الف لاجئ من اصل كل هذا
العدد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات